hey dr. Berg here in this short video I
want to talk about my health coach
training because you may want to become
a health coach this course can be spread
out over a period of time if you do it a
little bit each night it will take you
eight weeks if you do it more intensely
you can get it done in a whole week but
it's all online and this is what's in
the course the course is the balance of
the videos and practical so you'll be
doing little practical exercises until
you complete the entire checklist of
information so you're going to be
learning about all the eating plans how
to put people on the right eating plan
for their body type you're going to
learn about the rules of eating all the
things the do's and the don'ts I really
try to keep it as simple but there's
there's some stuff that you need to know
we'll talk about the myths the missing
information that people need to know the
most important information that people
need to know you'll learn about the fat
burning foods in relationship to eating
based on hormonal health so you'll learn
about the fat burning foods and then the
fat making hormones and what foods
trigger each one because this is very
cool because most people are focused on
just calories or balancing your proteins
carbohydrates and fats but not the
relationship between how food interacts
with hormones okay then you're going to
learn about acupressure there's twelve
videos I'm going to be uploading some
more on there and it shows you how to
get someone to do it on themselves
there's one also on sinus discomfort
there's one on the menstrual discomfort
and sleep in general pain and general
stress so unless you're a massage
therapist chiropractor or another
practitioner your license to do it you
can only teach people how to do it on
themselves versus doing it on them okay
so that's acupressure exercise
technology you're going to learn my
exercise technology which is very very
very powerful because a lot of tape if
you have a person that's exercising
they're not seeing much results you can
go in there and dissect why they're not
getting results and fix it so that way
they're Prag
is so much better so this is going to be
a amazing technology just in itself then
the most valuable thing of this whole
health coaching is my method method of
evaluation how to take a symptom as a
clue pull the string and find out a root
cause so you're going to be looking at a
person's energy level in their sleep
their digestion they're paying their
inflammation their cravings their
menstrual cycle and be able to take that
dig deep find out the real reason why
they can't lose weight or we can't get
healthy you'll understand the mechanisms
like why a certain person has a certain
symptom and what what that means so it's
like reading your body so that's very
very cool stuff then you can learn how
to coach someone what is the best way to
coach them and coaching is you're taking
some advanced information and you're
leveraging it to get an advantage over a
problem you're trying to solve an
obstacle and you're using certain
strategies to overcome those obstacles
that's how you coach someone so I use a
lot of things to leverage it so we're
using more wisdom than just you know
like hey just keep trying harder you
know we don't want to do that and then I
show you how to educate someone so they
retain the information and they really
get it and they have a lightbulb go off
so we're going to show you how to do
that as well I'll show you some tips on
promoting yourself and then also it
includes the fat burning quiz for one
year as well as the health coaching
portal for one year too and that has all
the tool tools so you can interact with
your people and get their eating plan
back and just dissect it and tell them
exactly what to do so it's a great
training program I really just want to
welcome you to our health coaching
program because we need more health
coaches this course will help people
basically learn how to help people
better so I will look forward to seeing
you enroll and and your success thank
you very much